eeuu podría retomar las relaciones que
barack obama mantenía con américa
latina' en temas como la lucha contra la
corrupción y la cercanía con los
gobiernos de la región bardem ha dicho
que es prioritario recuperar el
liderazgo ahora que china ganó más
terreno durante el mandato de trump y se
convirtió en el mayor socio comercial de
américa latina' sin contar a méxico
[Aplausos]
relación con méxico
precisamente uno de sus grandes retos es
su relación con andrés manuel lópez
obrador quien ha manifestado apoyo a
trump en algunas de sus denuncias sin
fundamentos no me gusta que
a nadie
e
los censuren y le quiten el derecho de
transmitir un mensaje en twitter
6 by the no prometido además poner fin a
la separación de padres y niños en la
frontera con méxico aunque dice que
mantendrá los pactos con los países del
triángulo del norte para que frenen a
los migrantes en sus territorios
sostiene que les pedirá compromisos para
atacar la corrupción
[Aplausos]
relación con venezuela y cuba con la
llegada del demócrata a la casa blanca
también podrá haber un giro frente a
venezuela
aunque vaivén calificada abiertamente a
nicolás maduro como un dictador también
ha defendido que las elecciones son la
única vía lejos de la intervención
militar cuba espera que la nueva
presidencia también marque una
diferencia para ellos ahora que la
nación caribeña volvió a la lista de
países que apoyan al terrorismo nosotros
estamos convencidos que el presidente de
baile y su equipo de gobierno conocen
perfectamente y reconocen que cubano es
ni ha sido un país patrocinador del
terrorismo
brasil y la deforestación
el presidente de extrema derecha jair
bolsonaro niega la deforestación en la
amazonía un tema que bardem ha criticado
las selvas tropicales de brasil están
siendo talados están siendo devastadas
colombia y la fumigación aérea
mientras trump respaldó la postura del
presidente iván duque de volver a la
expresión aérea de glifosato baiden es
más partidario de erradicar las hojas de
coca y de atacar estructuras de
narcotráfico otro de los cambios que
podrían darse con la nueva presidencia
de eeuu